normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we got
big news ladies and gentlemen house
votes to formalize Republican
impeachment inquiry into Joe Biden I
love how they have to put Republican but
technically it would just be the
impeachment inquiry because the
Republicans have the majority the 221 to
212 party line vote opens a door for the
GOP to get more evidence about schemes
that have been that have seen the Biden
family get millions from countries
including China Ukraine Romania and
bidens will will now have more of their
bank records mortgage details emails
text messages and mobile phone subpoena
along with anything else Congress wants
to see since start of 23 Republicans
have been investigating Joe Biden over's
alleged connections to his son Hunter's
extremely lucrative multi-million dollar
influence pedling scheme spanning
decades with a formal impeachment
inquiry vote Republicans say the White
House can no longer Stonewall them for
requested documents and depositions but
top goop leaders have argued it wasn't
necessary you do not need a full vote of
the house to do an impeachment inquiry
to do the investigation that we're
constitutionally obligated to do GOP
whip Tom emmer told the Daily Mail ahead
of the vote but this is basically
showing there the the Republican party
is investigating Joe Biden it is
formalized they will have more powers
and this is step one this is what we
kept we kept arguing about they they
would say like oh we're we're going to
uh we the impeachment in Korea is coming
it's coming we're like yeah yeah and so
the story was Kevin McCarthy vows to uh
have hold inqu into whether or not there
should be a vote on whether or not there
should be an impeachment inquiry and now
Kevin McCarthy's gone and now they'
finally formalized the impeachment
inquiry process this so I'll explain it
in non-political terms they have
formally launched a criminal
investigation into Joe Biden should they
find a preponderance of evidence they
will launch an impeachment also known as
an indictment or other words an
indictment the indictment leads to a
trial and should Biden be convicted that
will be the conviction in impeachment
and the removal from office I don't
believe that's very likely but this is
the criminal investigation phase of Joe
Biden's impeachment process I kind of
I've been sensing it man when Hunter
stood in front of was that this morning
or yesterday morning I think and just
refused to answer he he made a statement
then left and then did he leave like a
BRI he avoided his trial and I will
probably have a different opinion on
that and I I hate when Republicans put
me in these kind of positions of like
I'm going to have to defend Hunter Biden
I'm not defending him but he wanted it
to be a public hearing
from the way I hear it you know what if
Congress ever hauled my butt in for
anything like I want this public
like I just really like the idea that
for whatever reason they didn't want to
have a I understand he's going to Grand
stand he's going to try to make his
point his views Etc but I think it's
fair to say yeah if I'm going to be hul
in front of con Congress I want it to be
public I think that's a fair statement I
think that's a fair stat so why can't
the Republicans say hey you know what we
can handle our own PR for this we'll let
him come in and say what he wants to say
and we'll refute it live in front of the
I'll be open to that but so he refused
to do it unless it's public and they're
hey that violates the rules you have to
do it's not a violation rules violation
what they wanted it was this on top of
Joe Biden answering reporters questions
they're like hey what's up with these
business dealings and he's like you're
lying you're all lying and I'm like oh
this is coming man I just saw this this
feels like it's been coming they don't I
don't think anybody wants him to run as
president and he won't let go I do I
want him to run yeah I'm all for Biden I
I made Biden Federman t-shirts I want
fetman to be the VP on on his ticket
there because you know obviously
obviously it's a noer but but but not
just that but because clearly he is
sticking to his guns he's saying I'm not
leaving even a couple weeks ago the
Speaker of the House said oh you know
there's nothing to really investigate
Joe Biden on and a lot of people are
saying well that's kind of strategic
right before this election cycle because
if we do impeach him if we do
investigate him this might potentially
make him not be able to run for the
presidency of the United States is this
going to be something that's going to be
happening now with this impeachment why
is there a sudden shift in in Congress
they have no spine there's no sh shift
is a different excuse they just don't
have to go through with it no they need
to get rid of Biden this is not good for
Trump right oh yeah right the question
is how do you remove Joe Biden if Joe
Biden gets
impeached convicted and then they
criminally and then they they criminally
convict Donald Trump they will say we've
been impartial the whole time Joe Biden
went down for corruption and Donald
Trump and now we have Nome V de santis
and you know who wins that election
Nome unfortunately you correct why do
you you think is this going to be Dan
santis well excuse me well I mean he's
he's
he's be even worse I mean I'm being
hopeful when
I Nome Nikki Haley who do you vote for
oh I vote for Haley over
that Wald or I mean well I'm not saying
I would enjoy that vote like why do you
be such a terrible option I mean that's
usually the election cycle in America
sandwich but I
wased the worst of those is that I think
Nikki Haley would get us a war with Iran
whereas Gavin would capitulate to the
financial he get us in a war with
ourselves he he would spark a civil war
from from my perspective but you think
vi just the media hates him too much
they're going to they're going to try
and stop him and make him look like a
bad guy I think Trump would
automatically and say hey VC should be
the president because V's the only
person who said that he would pardon
Donald Trump if he would become the
president of the United States and
didn't hesitate to say that so I think
Vivic might have a path here with how
tulous and crazy the situation could get
here as of course if Donald Trump I'm
I'm rooting for a Vivic if I can't run
and I can't be the president of the
United States Tucker too yeah Tucker
could be V well Tucker always made these
kind of statement saying you know I
don't want to be a politician but it's
always the Pol the people who don't want
to be politicians that should be the
politicians so he always has a way of
kind of saying these things and making
people understand that there is a sense
of Duty and responsibility when it comes
to public office that he understands
even though he says he doesn't want it
but then he describes people who don't
want it as the people who should be
there so duplic messages and this is why
tuck Carlson 2024 this I got the T-shirt
I'm going to sell a lot more of them if
this if this becomes the case but it's
not just about the t-shirt it's about
the future of this country that uh is uh
in a very dangerous situation right now
it's really funny because uh okay so if
Joe Biden gets impeached kamla Harris
will take over but she will likely say
I'm not gonna run she's probably gonna
Pro in the event Biden is impeached and
convicted removed Kamala becomes acting
president and says I'm not going to
spend the one year I have to help the
American people campaigning and then
she's going to say you know the
Democrats will have a process to
determine who the nominee shall be and I
will I will protect the office and this
country for the remainder of this term
then she bows out then Nome steps in and
it's going to be you know Nome and who
do you think his VP is going to be
Lucifer I don't know Satan what if what
if it's Nome Haley versus like DeSantis
Nome Michelle Obama maybe right
it would be interesting to see people
from multiple parties come together to
one party here's here's right that's the
same party Newsome and
halot Chris Christie and this is why uh
uh I think it's really really funny a
year or two ago we're all like impeach
this this what what the bidens have been
doing for years and now we're close to
the election like no no no no no no no
keep there people decide I think your
Congress call your congressman and say
no impeachment we want Biden to stay I
kind of I feel like if Biden stay he win
again just because of the way the
systems uh unfortunately I don't like
the way the media canel people to vote a
certain way just by convincing them it's
very very very very powerful hey Ivon
musk has actually had a huge change on
what the next election will be based on
Twitter now X so they were able to
censor so much that just never could
make it through on the old Twitter that
won't happen this time I've I've said
this multiple times like as an example
our Beer Company would not exist without
Elon Musk reason being we would never
have been allowed to go viral to the
level that we did anywhere other than an
Elon Musk owned Twitter uh you can look
at what we did on other platforms hardly
anything yet on Twitter we have almost
50 million views yet magically on
Facebook Instagram all those places you
maybe get a million if even that if we
had real free speech if we had the
ability to actually talk to each other
without algorithms and censorship
efforts Donald Trump would have been the
president of the United States right now
he would have not lost but it's because
of the censorship it's because of the
manipulation because of the fortifying
why essentially Joe Biden was allowed to
be where he is right now because he was
able to censor stories like the hunter
Biden laptop story from the general
public which we know played a major
impact on the election so free speech is
important here and I think this is why
there's so many attacks on Elon Musk
trying to destroy him trying to take
down Twitter because if you take down
Twitter you could essentially fortify
all the elections in the future did did
you see NBC newses breaking story I I
just love this they wrote an article and
it said the Tesla's new Cyber truck
weighing at 6800 lb could be lethal in
collisions with pedestrians and smaller
cars experts worn and I was like Wow Wow
don't get hit by truck breaking news but
this is how much they're going after
Elon Musk they actually wrote that news
story
incredible about a recall about the the
sof again oh oh no real quick this
pissed me off it's been reported
everywhere recalls all vehicles to fix
dangerous thing what it really means is
Tesla issues software update you won't
even notice I was about to say you don't
even have to go in anywhere to get it
from what I understand it's just a
download through your system Tesla right
but they're calling it a recall oh yeah
no it's it's it's it's complete BS
you're you're going to wake up and your
app's going to be like updated you're go
oh whatever I want to do a soft
correction of what you said about Joe
Biden censoring the hunter thing cuz I
don't think I don't think there's
evidence that he did it directly it was
just that I think there's evidence the
FBI was involved then uh but it was the
intell presid this you might consider
that he he was I don't know if he was
directly involved but it was his son was
was the one that was under investigation
you g to vote for Trump
Luke um maybe possibly I still want to
be one I still want to be one who the
hell are you going to vote for I want to
have this conversation man bear pig
there's you go that
over it it depends uh it depends who's
running I I I I do think obviously if if
if I have to Trump it okay you you don't
have to vote for anybody I'm explaining
it I I I had a friend hit me up and he's
like are you seriously he's like a
liberal guy he's like are you seriously
considering voting for Donald Trump and
I was like considering I was like I'm
voting for Donald Trump and then he was
like why and and he said all of the bad
things Trump has done and I'm like I'm
not even going to argue with you
anything you think that that Trump will
do to this country that is bad than I
think America deserves based on its
foreign policy and Trump's first uh term
was no new Wars and that is what we must
do so my view is this first of all
economy was great I think Trump actually
did a pretty good job considering the
weights tied to his ankles he did some
bad things but I think it was an overall
net positive if the reality was this
country will be in hard times but no new
Wars take it but the reality is it's
going to be better with no new Wars so
my argument to the liberal guy is oh you
agree with the military-industrial
complex you want to vote for Biden and
have more war in the Middle East South
America Europe no okay vote for Trump I
I just I hope he can keep his cool
that's a big part he kept his cool his
whole term there was literally no new
war he used to tweet a lot about like
those radical he would like incite the
Left Right Paradigm no but that's what
kep us out of some it's going to depend
who who his VP is going to be as well
because if it's if it's someone that's
going to be like another mik Pence if
he's going to be surrounding himself
with Henry Kissinger again and John
Bolton again and all these other
horrible
individual if it's Nikki Haley yeah
wasn't k no if it's Nikki Haley would
you not vote for him you would vote for
Biden or n Haley or Biden no no no if
Trump chose Nikki Haley which I think
would be horrific as his VP would you
vote for why vote why vote at all then
that's what I'm
asking I I will promise you this then
that's a vote for Donald Trump draws a
gigantic pentagram on the on the ground
in a black robe and summons the zombie
corpse of Kissinger I also will not vote
for him thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net